[Music]
he's stupid and plump and targeting
Trump but for the common criminal the
prosecution's minimal it's time for
this city streets are a disaster so it's
the former president he goes after yep
it's Alvin Bragg's repellent Adventure
[Music]
I don't know how I feel about that
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg May indict
Trump any day now alleging he paid us
money the Stormy Daniels it's not
happening it's a testament to how
crime-free New York City is otherwise
you wouldn't have time for crap like
this
it'll make Bragg the first prosecutor
ever in the history of History to arrest
a former American president up until now
he was just the first prosecutor in
history to eat his body weight in
blueberry pie
[Applause]
's back stupid
of course all while letting deranged
criminals toss Asians in front of trains
in the city between 2019 and 2021
prosecutions have dropped 25 percent
even though shootings Rose by 102 and
murders by 51 Bragg blames a new law but
it was his policies on crime that are as
soft as his flabby ass he's so soft on
crime he's been made the centerfold of
Subway shovers magazine
[Applause]
thank you
yeah he's downgraded felonies to
misdemeanors while not seeking prison
sentences for offenders when someone
commits a violent crime he looks the
other way like he walked in on Al
Franken changing
but he's ready to throw the book at
Trump telling house Republican lawmakers
he will not be intimidated well at least
throwing a book burns calories meantime
the media is lapping up like idiots take
the so-called protests outside Trump
Tower and the Manhattan Court they'd
have you believe it's words of trumpers
waiting to Riot there weren't the media
also corralled two anti-trumpers and
zoomed in so it appeared they were one
of many fact is the Press far
outnumbered protesters I haven't seen an
exaggeration like that since Jesse
Waters claimed to know the whole
alphabet
Liz did Trump just Punk everybody yeah
because it feels like this thing is
falling apart he gambled it looks like I
mean it seems to me that this is this is
now becoming
hilarious it's unbelievable it's
astounding that what we're seeing in
real time that Trump did this over the
weekend he sent him got about to be
arrested within days and now by the hour
this is steadily eroding and falling
apart now Robert Costello Michael uh
Cohen's former legal advisor saying you
I gave you 321 emails you Cherry Picked
six that's what he's saying and then you
took them out of contest I mean context
this is eroding by the hour and by that
by the way what do New York taxpayers
paying for right I mean under Alvin
Bragg it's like do the crime don't do
the time you know so so where's his
focus and what you what they want to
know is now James Comer and my show just
said that he they're going to go after
whether or not the White House and the
doj we're talking Alvin Bragg before
they brought this try to bring this case
this is so sweet I mean part of me is so
angry Tyrus about the situation in New
York that this is what our D.A is doing
oh you should be yeah yeah you we all
should be angry at this but at the same
time listen if there's a place you're
going to get arrested Let It Be New York
he won't even miss his tea time in
Maryland
especially if he gets aggressive yeah if
he punches one of the arresting officers
Beyond in Florida in no time here's the
thing they can't arrest the president on
a Tuesday it can't be a Wednesday or
Thursday it has to be Friday so we'll be
stuck for the whole weekend talking
about it right and all this is about is
he needs to make the walk they have to
CNN needs this
they need this if anyone has watched any
of this coverage they're like they need
this
they've got 47 panelists per show with
families to feed they need this last
night they were like we're going to play
the interview his lawyer said last year
and said this year got him Coach they're
so excited there's no case do something
pick a fight with him we have to arrest
him on Friday they just need the
Handcuff thing because they are really
really afraid because their chosen one
the Great
well he did bring us all together
because we're pissed yeah but they're
they're president and their their
Administration is failing miserably so
the coup that they put up for four years
to get rid of
the orange monster there's a chance he
might be gaining momentum and coming
back right this is they're giving him
the oxygen they need the you got to have
the Handcuff yeah that's a thing cat the
media is doing the same thing it did in
2016. it's handing the oxygen over to
Trump well actually the media would have
to say a lot of the opposite stuff that
they said because the whole thing that
they have to prove here would be that
the only reason this payment was made
was because you know of the election it
was a campaign thing so all the pundits
were saying it was so horrible that he
cheated on his pregnant wife would have
to say oh that she would have no reason
to be upset about that it wouldn't be
like he wouldn't want her to find out it
would only be the voters that don't you
know they don't want the voters to find
out the same voters who they spent years
saying doesn't matter what he does they
don't even care right so I if you if you
want to say why he shouldn't be or
couldn't be convicted here all you would
have to do is look at all of the things
anti-trump people were saying for years
and years and years that's the exact
reason for it so I I there's no way that
this actually happens if you you just
take Trump out of it because he's so
polarizing it's really flimsy there's a
million reasons why you wouldn't want it
to be public that you that you did
something like that yeah other than
running for president you know Jamie uh
do they have water coolers up in Alaska
and what are they saying around those
those water coolers we have ice coolers
and we stand right inside of them and
and we fish
um tarnish made a great Point even if he
got arrested he would be out right like
they say criminal uh New York City
criminal cases are very similar to
tickets to my comedy shows and that 70
of them are thrown out
um
it's funnier when I don't Mumble
the Stormy Daniels thing is fat this is
a joke and this is going to dissolve and
it's going to go away like the Stormy
Daniels thing I'm also I'm not like a
big porn guy and even when I watch it I
only watch like two to three minutes
right but
what I like Trump paid this woman he
slept with a porn star and he paid her
hush I guess you would call it like hush
my if I slept with a porn star I would
pay her tell everybody money
thank you
you know it's go ahead I was just gonna
say you know times are hard and they
asked me to record a few PSAs to to help
people with some advice oh okay you
wanna do you want to roll one oh sure
blissow's lessons tips from a divorced
dad
[Music]
alcohol sex drugs somebody's gonna need
to talk to your kids about these
important subjects play your cards right
and it won't be you
[Music]
[Applause]
know
really makes you think doesn't it
how much your kids hate you I'm kidding
they love Jamie hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else